wenn ich auf toilette habe ich mich sehr
gefreut name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
blog auf einem kanal
wie gefällt euch meine rabatt heute ist
ein ganz besonderer tag meine damen und
herren denn meine haare sind scheiße wie
immer also es ist eigentlich ein
komplett normaler tag gut man empfehle
allen die heute ist der erste tag seit
drei jahren an dem ist nicht 30 grad
sind seht ihr das da oben das sind
wolken
ich liebe den saubermann kann rausgehen
man kann alle sachen machen die man im
winter machen kann auch im sommer machen
kann sagte deutscher früher auf dem
gymnasium und dann auch im abi war immer
mein lieblingsfach ist aber auch egal
dass auf jeden fall sachen draußen
machen die man auch im winter machen
kann und wenn man die dann im sommer
macht ist er auch egal man kann wird ich
habe auch egal ob in sachen machen die
man im winter machen können keine sommer
genau die sachen machen die man auch im
winter machen ich hatte eine firma wie
ich mag den sommer aber irgendwann ist
auch mal ende das wissen wir und im
sommer ist ein bisschen so wie mit der
familie an familienfesten also man freut
sich wenn sie da sind und was heute zeit
miteinander zu verbringen aber
irgendwann reicht es dann auch das kann
folgen weiß dass meine familie sieht der
jugend ich habe mundgeruch und mir noch
nicht die zähne geputzt
jetzt ihren neuen gut riechenden kurs
allerdings bereits im titel eingeblendet
ist meine sehr verehrten zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer etwas jude
und ich werden heute in einen ein euro
laden gehen
das ist glock dieser typische ein euro
laden und wir werden jeder zehnte euro
in die hand nehmen und getrennt
voneinander produkte kaufen für den
anderen und wir schauen dann nach rwe
für 10 euro die besseren produkte sag
ich mal gekauft hat und ihr dürft danach
über eine umfrage entscheidet und ich
gehe ich aber erstmal kurz duschen
ich wünsche das erste bad hat sondern
decken ist was ganz ganz besonderes für
den pubertierenden jungen ich weiß auch
genau beim wellen bei mir war das so
mein erstes bad hat das hatte ich das
na ja wir haben wir morgen jetzt das
smsen style mit jule sieht man hätte ich
nicht sagen sollen
tut mir leid bitte nicht helfen es war
nur ein spaß
ich habe schon geld ab und jule trinkt
einen kaffee sondern eine weiße heiße
schokolade alle denken es juden grown up
girls weil sie kaffee trinkt also jeder
denkt es ist eine heiße schokolade
laufen jetzt auf jeden fall zum nächsten
tedi und auf die idee dass man ein euro
laden das sind die ringe meine damen und
herren hier sind oft komische gestalten
juli darf ich jetzt in diesem thema hier
angekommen sind würde ich sagen hier von
uns beiden bekommt ihr 10 euro und 10
euro eine menge große stange geld
was passt
wir brauchen übrigens für den anderen
sachen also wir denken dass sie dem
anderen gefallen also wir sehen es gar
nicht wieder einen korb kommen
[Musik]
wir waren nun einkaufen im tee die jule
hat ihre sachen ich habe meine sachen
die sache ist wir halten ob ich 11 euro
ausgeben wegen der typ 13 euro
ausgegeben ich dachte alles kostet 1
euro so ich war total falsch informiert
auf jeden fall laufen jetzt nach hause
wo wir dann uns gegenwärtig die sachen
geben und auspacken also meine damen und
herren wir sind wieder zu hause
angekommen ich warum schickst mich jetzt
kannst du dich bei mir entschuldigen
also ich hab jetzt gesamt 13 euro
ausweisen ausgegeben
julia hat 11 euro ausgegeben und ich
würde sagen dass wir jetzt abwechselnd
beim anderen in die tasche greifen und
derjenige erklärt und dann was er sich
dabei gedacht als jude law ist dass man
erst der anfang zu ziehen
die schultüte ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
habe das gesehen und dachte dass man das
so aufsetzt wirklich und was ich mir
dabei gedacht habe du hast ja am 16
november geburtstag und du willst ein
mädchen was es wirklich jedem mitteilen
möchte das ist am 16 november geburtstag
hat an alle die sich bis sie auf jeden
fall habe ich mir gedacht habe deinen
geburtstag immer so sehr magst und weil
du das mal gesagt dachte ich erst dass
der sonne sondern so ein hut aufsetzen
kann es aber es war leider eine
schultüte
[Musik]
ich kenne hier noch ein großes ding
freut mich für lüge darüber habe ich
mich nämlich eigentlich gar nicht
gefreut juli kräfte wieder rein und sie
hat ja und was habe ich mir dabei
gedacht
richtig gar nicht immer wenn man mit
jule auto fährt ist sie diese die dabei
fahrer der nach einer gewissen zeit mir
ist langweilig was er essen man da was
zu trinken
katy perry hat und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht den werde ich mir ab sofort ins
auto packen das heißt wenn wir längere
zeit unterwegs sind kann hiermit zum mit
seinem kag würfel kannst du dann rätsel
lösen
max brothers für klug und wir haben da
sie ein lufterfrischer wenn ich auf
toilette war habe ich mit noch an mich
gedacht
gemeinwesens produkt für juli spielen
meine lieben freunde und das ist dabei
habe ich mir gedacht weil juli meinte
letztens im barnim fehlt etwas wo sie so
hohe sachen rein stecken kann deswegen
hab ich das sie gekauft
das ist scheiße das ist nicht komplett
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wird dein auto du liebst du jule
hangen ursachen geholt damit sympath
besser riecht damit in der küche die
küchenrolle nicht mehr umstellen und
damit in meinem auto sauberer als
hintermann hinterhalt aber das ist das
werde ich mir tatsächlich wirklich damit
müssen
dazu gehe ich gleich noch mal ein
ich hatte deutschland kam aber wie
deutschland das habe ich gesehen und ich
dachte ich muss es dir kaufen
juli die vermisste end messe wird auch
das was wir da mal gedacht habe ist bei
juli zu hause im im zimmer steht ein
foto von uns zwei
[Musik]
ich würde meinen gerade ist die nächste
sache die ich ziehe die letzte sache ist
und mein gott das ist dass ich sag mir
wer derart oktoberfest der ey du machst
dir echt klasse nächstes produkt für
junge leute du musst du nicht auch deine
augen zu machen da war ich noch auf
morgen zu also aber juli zieht draußen
und jetzt ist was habe ich mir hier
beide juristen bisschen mädel frau und
sohn mehrere frau die immer in ihrem
portemonnaie wirklich alles möglich ein
kleingeld trat deswegen hier eine
sparbüchse für dich bei jule allerdings
nicht mehr für mich gekauft hat dafür
habe ich den super duper sachen
küchenrollen halter für vier euro
nächstes produkt auf jule natürlich auch
hier auspacken einer tüte erst mal
rausnehmen und da haben wir nämlich eine
bmw zum geburtstag freunde hier für die
juli zum geburtstag ich schon mal
gekauft es gab übrigens nur 18 super
wenn man irgendwie 19 wird oder
irgendwie älter dann kann man einfach
kein wimpel nimmt eli kaufen das ist
eine dreierkette dich hast du dir den
ganzen tag umhängen nächstes produkt auf
unit natürlich auch wieder hier ziehen
bei mir weil yu na hat für mich
natürlich nicht so viel gekauft eine
maske
ich weiß warum ich die gekauft hat weil
du immer die ich nachts beschwert dass
es zu hell in meinem schlafen kannst du
dir aufsetzen dann wird es nicht mehr
hält besetzte andersrum auf der gedanke
zählt das nächste produkt ist natürlich
auch von mir für jude weil ich würde mir
nicht so viel gekauft hatte sind
gummibänder feier hat immer t shirt an
und da machte die manchmal ein bisschen
hoch oder gummi wenn du irgendwo
verloren wenn die sich die auszieht
deswegen hier ist ganz viele neue
produkt habe ich ebenfalls für die uno
gekauft weil
die huder hatten natürlich nicht so viel
für mich ja die weil du hast nägel ja
meine damen und herren man muss
natürlich bedenken dass ich auch 312
euro mehr aus dem jedem habe als die
liebe julia trotzdem könnt ihr jetzt
über eine umfrage die ich hoffentlich
diesmal nicht vergessen werdet ihr könnt
dort abstimmen wer von uns beiden wohl
bessere sachen für den anderen gekauft
hat also stimmt am besten alle für luca
ab ich dachte wir kaufen sinnvolle
sachen und nicht so eine scheiße hallo
gummibänder nagellack dose mister und
misses schild wenn ich die umfrage
vergessen haben sollte was 90 bis 100
prozent der fälle eigentlich mal der
fall ist könnte auch in die kommentare
schreiben
luca oder jude und gestenreich von lukas
freuden das war auf jeden fall unser
euro einkauf hier vorne freunde und wir
wollen das ist vielleicht noch mal kurz
auf allerdings wollte ich noch auf einen
kommentar eingeben
du kannst nicht böse gemeint aber seine
ein bisschen netter zu jule die momentan
in diese richtung wurde so circa 7000
mal unter den letzten blog geschrieben
in diesem video hatte die schule nämlich
klamotten bases bestellt ich hatte diese
ausgepackt und bewertet und ich fand
keines der kleidungsstücke wirklich cool
aus und dieses armband das habe ich
behalten und da waren einige leute sehr
sauer über meine reaktionen deswegen
eine lehrstelle leute es tut mir leid
dass es so rübergekommen ist als wenn
ich will nur fertig gemacht hätte bin
ganz ehrlich sagen die junge mieter
stellt trafen einfach nicht so ganz mein
geschmack aber das ist doch sehr sehr
sehr sehr schwierig und dazu unmöglich
den geschmack einer person genau zu
treffen bei mir war dass er dir ohne
spezielle witzig gemeint ist derzeit ein
bisschen schade dass das nicht so
richtig gut angekommen ist und viele
leute dass ich oder einfach nur fertig
machen wollte also ich glaube jeder weiß
dass schule liebe so die würde ich nun
mal so krass fertig machen allerdings
solltet ihr auch vielfach dass ich mal
für die ursachen von bestell- und ich
denke das wird dann ähnlich ablaufen
also bitte leute lasst euch gesagt sein
es ist alles cool es tut mir leid dass
es so gekommen ist tatsächlich ein
bisschen schlecht behandelt ist
vielleicht habe ich das ja auch
also wenn das so viele leute schreiben
dann kam es glaube ich wirklich so über
einen story ein vollidiot und hat mit
falschen adapter für mein macbook
bestellt und deswegen müssen wir uns
zurück senden und dann hat noch zehn
minuten auf es hat noch geklappt freunde
und wir sind sogar erfolgreich aus dem
laden rausgegangen mitnehmen
erst als erwarteter shop für julia ist
ja nicht so dass wir morgen nach paris
fahren und zu hause bleiben wollen um
die sind einkaufen gehen das 1 7-fache
sind zwei blumentöpfe ist schön wenn ich
immer nur drauf audi zu stecken desto
mehr übrig sein indisches essen bestellt
die kastration regierung immerhin grund
leute das ist die schönste nachricht des
tages indisches essen bin ich ganz
ehrlich ist nicht jedermanns sache so
ein paar leute sind halt echt
empfindlich was was schärfe und so
angeht ich bin da wie dort panzer bei
der es eigentlich alles einfach so ein
freund von ihm von mir ab
[Musik]
halb in der alle städte durch den
heutigen lockt jetzt allerdings auch
beende meine damen und herren es ist
schon sehr sehr spät und wir fahren
morgen nach paris daher okay ich meinen
wir fallen irgendwann um 17 uhr los
auch ein spiegel dennoch sind wir müde
wir waren auch gestern nahmen noch einen
gin und wir haben halt den todes
muskelkater beide deswegen last leichter
wenn es euch gefallen hat wenn es euch
nicht gefallen hat was gern dislike dort
jeder kann bewerten wer das will will
ich würde mich natürlich sehr freuen
wenn euch diese blogs gefallen vor allem
jetzt mit dieser neuen modern family
stromberg fusion die office art sache
mit meinen zwischen schnitten oder so
für mich ist dieses werk einfach was
cooles neues erfrischendes ich kann neue
sachen ausprobieren kann mich ein
bisschen weiterentwickelt und so weiter
und so fort aber ich bin einfach nur
noch mal spaß und ich sollte das jetzt
doch endlich beenden
[Musik]